in 1845 Ireland's vast potato fields
were struck by an invasive fungal
disease that rapidly infested this
staple crop the effect was devastating 1
million people died of famine and over a
million more were forced to leave
Ireland nowadays we avoid such
agricultural catastrophes with the help
of pesticides those are a range of
manmade chemicals that control insects
unwanted weeds funguses rodents and
bacteria that may threaten our food
supply they've become an essential part
of our food system as populations have
grown monoculture single crop farming
has helped us feed people efficiently
but it's also left our food vulnerable
to extensive attack by pests in turn
we've become more dependent on
pesticides today we annually shower over
5 billion pounds of pesticides across
the earth to control these unwanted
visitors the battle against pests
especially insects has marked
Agriculture's long history records from
thousands of years ago suggest that
humans actively burned some of their
crops after harvest to rid them of pests
there's even evidence from ancient times
that we recruited other insects to help
in 300 AD Chinese farmers specially bred
ferocious predatory ants in orange
orchards to protect the trees from other
bugs later as large-scale farming spread
we began sprinkling arsenic lead and
copper treatments on crops but these
were incredibly toxic to humans as well
as our demand for more safer produce
increased so did the need for effective
chemicals that could control pests on a
grander scale
this assured in the era of chemical
pesticides in 1948 a Swiss chemist named
Paul Hermann Muller was awarded a Nobel
Prize for his discovery of
dichlorodiphenyltrichloroethane also
known as DDT this new molecule had
unparalleled power to control many
insect species until the 1950s when
insects became resistant to it worse the
chemical actually drove dramatic
declines in bird populations poisoned
water sources and was eventually found
to cause long-term health problems in
humans by 1972 DDT had been banned in
the United States and yet traces still
linger in the environment today
since then chemists have been searching
for alternatives with each new wave of
inventions they've encountered the same
obstacle rapid species evolution as
pesticides destroy pest populations they
leave behind only the most resistant
individuals they then pass on their
pesticide resisting genes to the next
generation that's led to the rise of
superbugs such as the Colorado potato
beetle which is resistant to over 50
different insecticides another downside
is that other bugs get caught in the
crossfire some of these are helpful
predators of plant pests or vital
pollinators so erasing them from
agriculture wipes out their benefits too
pesticides have improved over time and
are currently regulated by strict safety
standards but they still had the
potential to pollute soil and water
impact wildlife and even harm us so
considering all these risks why do we
continue using pesticides although
they're imperfect they currently may be
our best bet against major agricultural
disasters not to mention mosquito
ORN diseases today scientists are on a
quest for alternative pest control
strategies that balance the demands of
food production with environmental
concerns nature has become a major
source of inspiration from natural plant
and fungal chemicals that can repel or
attract insects to recruiting other
insects as crop bodyguards
we're also turning to high-tech
solutions like drones programmed to fly
over crops these machines can use their
sensors and GPS to carry out more
targeted sprays that limit a pesticides
wider environmental impact with a
combination of biological understanding
environmental awareness and improved
technologies we have a better chance of
finding a holistic solution to pests
chemical pesticides may never shake
their controversial reputation but with
their help we can ensure that
agricultural catastrophes stay firmly in
our past
you